I hate cord-cutting hate the triumphant
vigor with which we say it if you
stopped paying for cable TV you still
have to pay someone probably the same
cable company to get the Internet to
your house it gets there on a cord and
you are definitely paying too much for
it it is really expensive to run cords
to everyone's houses it would be
expensive if you were doing it with yarn
and so far only two kinds of companies
in America have figured out how to do it
the phone company and the cable company
now most telephone companies didn't pay
to upgrade their copper to high-speed
Internet access
so we're really just left with a cable
company this is a natural monopoly
almost every other developed country in
the world handles this through the idea
of common carriage it varies from
country to country but basically one
company owns the cord and any other
company has the right to buy access to
the cord to sell you the Internet this
takes a natural monopoly and it creates
competition but that's not what we do
here in the United States the same
company that owns the cord to your house
is the company that's selling you
Internet access there's no competition
that's why you hate your cable company
because they don't have to compete with
anybody else for your affection do you
want to get angry in France in socialist
France there's a company called free it
got its start buying access to common
carrier copper that went to everybody's
houses it will now sell you a gigabit
that's a thousand megabits plus you know
access to three million hotspots around
the country free international calling a
blu-ray DVD player and a game controller
it will sell you all of this for 30
euros a month
that's $38 if you want to pay another
two euros you get a hundred and ninety
seven TV channels in the US even if
you're blessed enough to have Verizon
FiOS you won't get more than 29 megabits
and the average price for that speed is
about 57 dollars the FCC is thinking
about changing this policy and applying
common carriage here in the US this will
not happen because the FCC has no brass
so go ahead cut the cord and I'm using
the air quotes because you're not
actually cutting anything
the cable companies will get their money
out of you no matter what you do